[Musik]
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer 100 hunger games zusammen mit kran
zu dem crafter und zwar ich sehe dich
nichts für mich ich habe hier rum so die
schreibkraft und dabei der attachés
player was heißt es eigentlich wenn ihr
so zittern also jetzt kommt herr games
eventuell kommt nachher noch megaprojekt
wenn ihr 3000 likes schafft dann lade
ich das nach einer hoch nennt max kong
kraft rechts 3030 bringen noch nicht
folge megaprojekt du musst du sagen ich
laufe die einfach hinterher oder
schreibe einfach bitte nicht töten
direkt weil jetzt sind wir mal zusammen
auf einem server und die map gefällt mir
auch wirklich geht zuerst die mitte auf
jeden fall ja ich habe gar nichts hopp
ich lasse ihn der da kommt also hier
gibt es keine grace period es heißt wenn
es am anfang nicht geschützt werden
gerade darunter aufgenommen wurde max
einfach direkt am anfang getötet
sie wollen jetzt einen namen nennen weil
ich kein held auf gestalten wollen der
max ja ich habe auch die letzte aufnahme
habe ich auch nicht geredet also keine
ahnung ich gar nicht mal so was gar
nicht ausgerastet darüber wie man jetzt
einfach mal nichts drauf auf dem schiff
ich hoffe jetzt weiter ließ mich
übrigens leute ohne witz wenn ihr pvp
pro werden wollte einfach mal zum
äußeren macht einfach euer sichtfeld
richtig weit so wie ich ein schwert
bekommen wenn man das licht fällt weiter
sieht man viel mehr und man man weiß
nicht ich finde ich kann viel besser
jumpen und so was alles
ich finde es läuft voll dann ihr seht
hier ich hab hier war das wasser als
wäre es nichts mag ich bin des todes
gestorben aber der ein typ ist in dieser
höhle und jetzt komplett geschwächt
komplett geschwächt
hast du angst eingejagt mit seinen
blicken ich habe ich bin hinter der ich
habe schließlich haben sie getroffen
hier habe ich habe mein eigenes stinkt's
hier
ich glaub ich werde gleich von einer
kokosnuss getötet also ich habe kein
gold wert da unten ist das einer 500
christen keinen gott du bist gar keiner
kiss vorbeigelaufen und die sie gleich
denke ich hoffe ich nicht alter wer sich
dahinter sieht ihn nicht töten
schlaumeier heißt oder ist tot
[Musik]
ich hoffe roger junge chillig alter mich
ausgerüstet bin
barbara ausrüstung mit ihren 1
so etwas besser gold oder holzschwert
ich glaube also vom angriff schaden her
gleich aber deutschland hat vestberg
einfach erstmal weg aber viele leute
sagen dass das meer mehr krippen macht
was so widerwärtig springst genauso
wehrmachts mehr schaden schreiben die
leute immer aus und er ist ein typ
stimmt ich bin so geschwächt das schaffe
ich niemals du tötest junge du lebst du
noch viel mehr
die firma getroffen oder so er hat auch
grad ab von der haut ab
ja sicher aber ich habe keinen ich habe
aus den wein halbjahres in alter wie
dreieinhalb ja dann geh lieber weg ich
lasse ihn jetzt erstmal er kommt so
vorsichtig um die ecke hat und was liegt
dies nicht möglich
er schaut gerade nach dir
[Musik]
er bleibt er jetzt stehen gerade acht
mir kommt glaube ich soll er kommen ja
er kommt mit schlossen runter oder so
zunächst du das nicht einfach so
beiseite mit dir du penner h naja jetzt
habe ich wieder sieben herzen sieht man
halt kommt das ist ja gar nicht ja hast
du die kiste da drüben sehen klar hinter
dir ja klar da war ich dran da ist aber
nichts drin gewesen so ich geh jetzt auf
den drauf da kommen locker
er hat ein holzschwert nun aber da sie
ja dann hat genug leicht was auch erst
nicht um die ecke nicht kosten jetzt ja
genau ist okay ich frage auch nicht
wenn ich das wetter da unten so einer in
den wasser drin was machst du oben
stehst schnappen ketten haube und so was
alles springen ins wasser
wieso wie dumm wie es die kiste hier
oben leer und die ich hier nicht weil du
an der anderen kiste diesen typen
getötet hast jolo alter soll ich jetzt
ins wasser springen jungen schafft
diesen sprung in den deister zu
gefährlich nach rechts junge das wachs
jungen wo sind denn jetzt hier metern
kommt man ja hier
seitdem ist nur warum warum ich sage
jetzt mittlerweile immer belgien wenn
ich nicht weiß was ich schreiben so
jetzt hab ich chris einfach so belgien
geschrieben also jo sind hier noch
christen darauf wann die rede einfach
nicht mag sagt nix ich darf gar nicht du
bist ja einfach nur so hier sind sogar
was auch die ganzen sachen hab ich ja
schon dann ist ja auch noch eine kiste
genau und ich habe tnt
ich bin mir halt nicht sicher aber
vielleicht ist ja auch den master als
würde ich schätzen
ich bin grad nicht hoch aber im hätte
ich aber auch noch gedacht das wäre auch
noch hoch geklettert
aber ist da eine ich weiß es nicht da
ist wo doch schon gesehen er hält die
schnauze woche dreht sich ja ja ich
dachte also auf dem niveau sind leute
nein sagt nicht weihnachten t weihnacht
wird doch immer aufgefüllt ja genau
ja genau am besten geht es ums von mach
da was mit dem tnt
jetzt kann ich ja nicht mitnehmen aber
das steht ja nicht ohne grund da das ist
ja was er steht einfach runter ist so
etwas besonderes da ist locker eine
kiste drunter oder so du kannst es nicht
ab und ich dagegen geschlagen jetzt ein
anderes unternehmen setzen müssen
schillig max
jetzt nichts mehr also fünf gebote leben
noch 5 ja das heißt ich bin 20 prozent
der lebenden masse hier absolut sicher
ist mathe was nicht ja das ist doch
nicht sein dass so früh schon
traditionelle japanische spiel war ist
in counter das verschicken jetzt kein
dings man den kids day
ich laufe jetzt hier über stock und
stein
warum hast du dich am anfang sagt er
sich krank crafter bin ich bin crafter
2.0
er ist und max hat sich jetzt gezeigt ja
auf seinem kanal
ich besitze wollte jeder aussieht dann
geht auch ganz kanal einfach ja genau
oder ihr geht auf lukas kanal stellt ihr
euch mit braunen haaren vor ich sie
nämlich genauso aus allem ein er sieht
genau so aus wie ich und hatte einfach
nicht klug allerdings was quatsch links
ja die linke partei willst du doch
wählen
ja die linken halt aber eigentlich ich
bin mir nicht ganz sicher
naja ok das wollte sogar andeuten
einfach ne ja ich hab ich will die linke
ist nicht so recht jungen ich mache
wahlomat ist entweder 50 prozent doch
jung kann man bei allen raus irgendwie
ich sag dir schon sagt ja schon wenn ich
mich auch für rechts oder geradeaus oder
so um den titel um orientieren
naja das natürlich logisch man kann sich
natürlich dann auch mal um entscheiden
beiden beim ja von von links nach rechts
so dass man all das kann ganz schnell
passieren hat eben hätte ich links
gewählt
jährlich nehmen auch ein bisschen
weiterhin ein bisschen länger hätte ich
links gewählt
ein bisschen länger her hält zu legen
ist links gewählt ja es war warum ein
vor längerer zeit zu der zeit als du in
den tunneleingang ist jetzt rechts
natürlich rechts wählen
jetzt indes video wird es wieder
geradeaus zu er also die mitte
die grünen sogar ja ja ja klar ist was
haben wir denn auch soll es läuft wieder
raus natürlich wir haben ab sofort
mitmachen ab sofort so npd fdp und linke
okay okay es geht ja in kürze zur zeit
so wählen oder so zeit interessiert ich
politik gar nicht so in dem zurzeit
weniger also ich will's die bild jetzt
gerade geradeaus gehen aber da habe ich
ja letztes mal schon gewählt
herrlich hatte fdp wählen aber er ist
natürlich jetzt will ich npd wählen aber
die hat also habe ich ja schon mal
gewählt hast du schon mal gewählt
die taktik ist vielleicht doch nicht so
gut wenn man aufnimmt
wir machen ja klar polit comedy mit
zweiten boden ist dass hier gerade auch
ich merke schon wenig links wäre dann
natürlich mischen uw
ich sollte vielleicht einmal geradeaus
gehen eher der post hälfte war doch
nicht auf dem posten
die panels die linken ulrich krebs
richtig bock auf linke was denn ich hab
grad so richtig bock auf linke einfach
meister ja ich will pinkeln wählen
lincoln
oder halt ja da gerade hätte ich die npd
gewählt aber jetzt ihr fdp gerade
ja die fdp die bietet mir nur knochen an
alter oder die wähl ich doch nicht mehr
[Musik]
ansporn und batterien wie philipp jost
immer nicht alter junge fangen sich
damit an das haben wir so ein bisschen
haben wir machen es so wie es jetzt also
gar nicht okay ja wir lassen es einfach
dabei dass wir einfach so politiker
einfach einfach so fünf schwer taufen
hopfen soll ich mal jemanden eine
botschaft mit pilz hat mir seine besten
tipp gegeben für aber brot als ich lege
jetzt einfach ein rotes hier mit einer
kiste läuft berlin gut bezahlt mir so
ein tipp gegeben küste war stets gerade
im spinnennetz
[Musik]
was hat euch hingegeben 15 typen geben
für zwei games aufgabe und zwar gibt es
ja der ender perlen kosten ja das ist
der tipp alter es gibt ender perlen und
man kann ja man wird ja zum spot
teleportiert ne ja und wenn vans pont
airport ist kann man einfach die ender
perlen die luft schmeißen
er wird nun weg deportiert und dann
kommt die ender perla offen wenn es
wieder ganz woanders
wenn man schlechte ausrüstung hat was
ist denn spontan report junge stadt
häuschen hier gibt's ja deathmatch na ja
und das ist halt einfach spontan
pottbäcker david münchner arena
teleportiert sondern zum spontan ganz
schnell wieder weg lauft theoretisch
könnte man ja oder webseiten ändert dann
kommt kann man wieder dahin wo man von
wo man portiert wurde es ja gerade namen
gesehen
ich muss
dass nämlich viele leben dennoch
eigentlich 3d für ihn immer noch
darum ist noch eine kiste von iris
achten arena das match ja ja sollen die
kommen ein bett mensch jaja soll das
kommen lueg ag mal gehen wir geradeaus
also wer fdp ja nein ein umkehren
falsche entscheidung die linke linke den
berg hoch linke den berg hoch jetzt fdp
fdp ja genau da wo diese treppen sind
würde ich hin wählen wo welche treppen
sind alter da unten du bist du weit oben
schossen
da warten dieser in dieser höhe war noch
zur küste und war 100 prozent
woher du schaffst du schaffst es jetzt
jetzt links jetzt links zu npd gewählt
schill alter sehen sie konnten wir jetzt
schnell wie npd rechts rechts rein
[Musik]
ich sehe sie nicht als 80 geht doch mich
ich passe auf gerade niemand hinterher
doch jetzt alle alle ziemlich alter
läuft bei mir jetzt zwei laufen wir
hinterher laufen
warte wer hat den chat geschrieben
assist player devil team machen wir das
erstmal den hier und so dass tod und
auch der kreis ja ich sehe schon aber
das display kraft den nur wenige
schlicht suchen wir junge scheiße ich
muss irgendwas fressen jetzt hat er
opfert sich er opfert sich jetzt
unterstützen unterstützen unterstützt
sie junge [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] ich muss irgendwas fraser alter
hast du nichts
nein er ist tot jetzt greifen schnell
angeht sagt er dann gucken hingesetzt
ok jetzt machen wir sehr sorglos
teenager hochgehen
[Musik]
da machten fehlen kann dann musst du dir
alle runter wird ja ich muss mich
erstmal auskurieren
jeder ging der gewinn jeder in eine ecke
english please go into the corner in
dieser penner alter ok go
ich habe aber trotzdem noch drei herzen
die mir so übrigens zweieinhalb
schreiben einfach weiter so ne 2 in
wales zu schreiben hatte ich mal wieder
aufladen
[Musik]
gute combo locker da etwas macht der alt
er verliert sein ganzes tnt will einfach
jetzt daran hätte schlägt mit dem
spinnen weben her ja ich dachte ich kann
die setzen aber ich kann dem finale
irgendwie hinsetzen halte ich hab kein
bock ok drei kanister behindert wird ihn
töten wenn er gewinnt er hat einen stein
stärkung gibt es ihm übel muss um ihn
herum springen und schlagen nein navas
und wie hart scheiße alter der drei
herzen ja aber zwei schläge oder sondern
setzen ja egal ja ja ja aber hat dein
maul nämlich wird zweiter da es am
anfang schon gestorben sagt besser seite
gute für dich töten ich manchmal
manchmal sage ich auch sagen meinte so
wie ich sage
also für dich zumindest gute sache kommt
wird der mord folgejahr na ja leute die
gesagt 3000 lecks dann rief ich die
schätze dann kommt nachher noch mega
projekt richtig deine retten
ich möchte etwas zu fressen dann schauen
wir mal bilder schafft und dann kommt
eventuell nachher noch mega projekt und
auch die damit maxi am start und dann ja
also er ist jede unterstützung
max ist leise und wir beantworten wir
beantworten harry potter und privaten
harry potter fragen dann und natürlich
gerne half men die wird wahrscheinlich
noch ein bisschen länger gehen so 20 30
minuten so ok chillig dann wie gesagt
3000 likes wenn es euch gefallen hat
dann kann dies ja in die kommentare
schreiben wenn ihr mehr also normale
hunger games die da wollte und dann
sehen wir uns demnächst wieder oder
heute abend halt
[Musik]